there's been a whole lot of Iran in the
news first a surprise prisoner swap
between the u.s. and Iran then for
fulfilling its end of the nuclear deal
Iran finally saw crippling international
sanctions lifted but the very next day
the u.s. slapped on new sanctions the
United States is imposing sanctions on
individuals and companies working to
advance Iran's ballistic missile program
and we are going to remain vigilant
about it but despite that things are
looking better for Iran how so for
starters Iran will be able to rejoin the
world after years of isolation the
country has been excluded from the
global economy since its nuclear program
became public in 2002 Iran has always
insisted the program was for peaceful
purposes but that didn't stop the u.s.
the EU and the UN from imposing
sanctions to prevent the country from
developing nuclear military capabilities
and that was on top of several previous
US sanctions already imposed on Iran
since the 1979 revolution since 2010
alone Western sanctions Shrunk the
country's economy by an estimated 20%
now as part of the latest deal the US
will release anywhere from 55 to 100
billion dollars in frozen assets the US
will also allow the sale of aircraft for
commercial flights and the import of
Iranian goods like food and carpets and
the US will no longer sanction foreign
individuals or companies for buying oil
and gas from Tehran however the US will
maintain some sanctions related to what
it calls terrorism and its human rights
record in case you missed it iran holds
the second largest oil reserves in the
Middle East so restoring iran's access
to the world economy means exporting oil
lots of it this comes at a time when oil
prices have been at their lowest in over
a decade due to a deliberate oversupply
in the market and many experts predict
that the flood of new oil from Iran will
push prices down even further the
biggest winners in lifting the sanctions
the Iranian people international
sanctions have taken a devastating toll
on everyday
iranian s-- economic isolation they're
led to widespread unemployment sanctions
have prevented the shipment of all goods
and services to and from Iran hurting
critical industries like construction
transportation and health care this has
created a black market in which the cost
of everyday goods like food skyrockets
now with sanctions lifted Iran's
president hopes for fifty billion
dollars in foreign investment and a
significant bump in economic growth over
the next fiscal year not everyone is so
excited namely Iran's neighbors Saudi
Arabia the Gulf countries and Israel are
worried about what role and empowered
Iran could play in the region they've
stood against the Iran deal and the
lifting of sanctions
so while Iran is being brought out of
international isolation doesn't have to
worry about being even more isolated by
its own neighbors
you